from timcast.com new report finds U.S
military is weak unable to win a single
major regional conflict analysis
identified profound lack of seriousness
as a contributing factor to the US
military's decline Ian you were just
talking about a lack of strong men yeah
I was wondering where they are why
Society is obsessed with people like
Donald Trump and Jordan Peterson these
these men that are giving young children
guidance like the the heroes of our
lives and it's because they were sent to
Afghanistan and Iraq on a false premise
that Saddam Hussein had weapons of mass
destruction which he didn't have they
were lied went to fight an unjust War
had their psychology destroyed knowing
that they were fighting some false
narrative and then their bodies blown
apart their friends destroyed and now
they're now now they're shaken and our
leaders are absent they are the one
they're supposed to be leading the
nation right now and instead we got
fauci I wrote
Joe 86 year old president how old is
this guy now 84 years old and he's
supposed to be our military commander
I think when you talk about where did
the strong men go and I understand your
point there too but something else that
I like to harp on a little bit is
it's you know testosterone if you look
at what's happened to male testosterone
over the years it's nearly half of what
it was 50 years ago so men today are not
the same men of 50 years ago and so I
think that that might explain a little
bit about where we're at and I think
that people until people start realizing
and addressing that it's not going to
change most 20 year olds have the same
testosterone levels as 50 and 60 year
olds
pfas huh pfas phthalates
glass glass bottle water I wrote about
Marco Rubio small water our soldiers are
some of the most badass humans on Earth
those dudes every time I meet a
returning I don't know if did you serve
in the military but every time I have an
opportunity to talk to someone that's
actually seen combat or experienced that
is like is like and it's like it's so
valuable to the human consciousness to
understand what that is and those people
to put their lives on the line like that
um but to have gone through a false War
I mean I don't know if would you call
that a false flag if the government says
he has weapons of mass destruction you
go in he doesn't yeah they said it was
they had bad and info George Bush Jr is
like we had bad intelligence well you
know what it's on you George they didn't
even go through a false fight they just
claimed it was and then it wasn't it was
like it was like the next level of false
Flags there was people within the
government that came out and said hey
there's no wmds here they were silenced
there they were shunned they were
threatened there was media organizations
there was there was activists coming
forward hey hey this is not true this is
not happening I should have just come
out it's been like ladies and gentlemen
Saddam Hussein is trying to trade oil in
Euro
and then people would be like huh we
need you to mobilize like Stormtroopers
and invade and Conquer their land
imagine how no one would have done it
people would have would have revolved it
they would have said no we're not
Invaders dude
you say that but I don't know that they
would Revolt I think what you're saying
is maybe the right thing but I don't
know that the people would have revolted
uh they would have worn the mask and
done as they're told like most
Republicans did and quote unquote
conservatives did and shut down their
country and done whatever the hell the
government told them people are sheep
but that's with an excuse like if we
told people the truth about Iraq then
they would not you could have kind of
had the truth on the pandemic early on I
guess my point is more a lot of the
people that even speak out and claim
they're conservative this that and the
other the vast majority of people are
following this is because the pandemic
rolls around in our male adult leaders
are broken from their service in the
military like this those are the guys
that are supposed to be in Congress
right now running the show these are the
leaders they're the ones that are the
brave ones I struggle with that if you
think that just because someone's in the
military makes them a great leader then
that means we've got Barracks full of
future presidents
I'm just saying so if you look at a lot
this yeah canceled on this I'm about to
say you got John McCain you got Dan
Crenshaw like if you do look they are in
unless you're maybe the true generals
and stuff like this they're kind of used
to following other orders from the
government and that's doesn't always
equal the best Congressman I know I'm
getting canceled I'm sorry they make
great politicians you know that's a
great point the multinational
corporations and the big Bankers are
their generals and they're just they
just follow the way I don't want to I
want to clarify I don't think that being
in the military makes you a great leader
but I think that great leaders are drawn
to military command
uh
and when you find out that you've been
commanding a military on a false premise
kicking indoors and Fallujah and killing
families okay do you sin the same with
the police though
uh
no no I don't know much are there
different systems to me I think putting
your life going and and willing to fight
like and kill people for why are you
assuming that's what the military is
yeah see and you don't understand
some people are like I want money all
right I want I want to be here
I mean guys guys enlisted there's no one
in this room who's a veteran okay right
not a single person let's say the
Holiday Inn last night and the most I
can say is that I've spent a few months
a couple different times on military
bases but let me tell you a lot of it is
just administrative work so assuming
that someone joining the military army
navy whatever it is is fighting is wrong
yeah yeah but some people are in support
of the fighting it's one or the others
yeah but bro someone might be like a
refrigerator repairman in Nebraska
that's repairing refrigerators for the
troops in Afghanistan
dude come on
yeah they're keeping the administration
going I'm trying to make is for the war
machine when you say that if you want to
make a point about people who have seen
combat it's different from the military
no no I'm talking about command command
structure basically somebody who
repaired refrigerators in Nebraska is no
different than a private refrigerator
repairman I mean I guess it went through
basically great leaders aren't drawn I'm
not saying maybe your refrigerator
payment and you are a great leader but
usually great leaders are drawn to
military command like they wanna they
wanna protect and serve the world I
think maybe you're picturing people of
the past that maybe the World War II uh
Era military veterans which a lot of
them did see combat if you were in World
War II and equating that to what today
is but I I just don't see it today when
a 22 year old is he gets a commission
and then outranks like a 45 year old NCO
like those those are funny scenarios
that I've seen as just someone as a
family member at the uh at like the what
is it called the commissary is that what
they call them I don't know because I I
just have family members and I'm like
buying food and I hear the grumbling
from the guy who's like a
non-commissioned officer being like why
is a 22 year old giving me the business
oh then he's got a bad Commander a good
22 year old okay bro come on a good 20
year old Commander will defer to his NCO
no yes no a good one will because he
doesn't always do he's great they
outrank him yeah but
deferred the guy with the experience in
real life
right now the military is training guys
uh how to wear heels right this that's
literally unfortunately she's not
happening right now Shattered by the war
in Iraq okay I think I think maybe you
can put part of the blame on the world
right but I'm just you know there's I
think a lot of other factors that come
into play and I do think you know kind
of my point about the police versus the
military you don't have the same belief
in police that are willing to put their
life their lives on the line Etc
I think you make a hard time jumping to
just because it's military police is
different military command I'm talking
about commanders the commanding force of
our military is like some of the
greatest humans on Earth that's why
they're in charge of our military and we
need those people in civilian life doing
the same thing Consciousness are these
the same people that you earlier talking
about committing the atrocities of
sending drones over and killing people
in frivolous Wars ordered by George Bush
well then you're not a dealer you're not
an effing leader
told because someone had a piece of
brass on their shoulder again I know I'm
getting canceled I'm sorry but
nonetheless like these people are still
following orders and that to me that
there's been a lot of horrific evil
that's taking place in the world because
of following orders and Donald Trump
Obama Bush Clinton all of these
presidents have the generals walk in and
say Here's what we're going to do and
why we have to do it and they say Okay
Donald Trump was very susceptible to
just believing that generals were smart
he put a lot of faith in the military
and he really believed what they had to
say and boy did they screw him over well
no and also you know Ivanka came in and
Jared came in and they're like we want
you to bomb Syria Trump's like okay go
bomb Syria and that's what Trump did
look that's according to Trump's own son
by the way not just hearsay and look at
what they did when Trump was like you
know what I'm getting our troops out of
Syria because I made a promise to the
American people and they went oh you got
it boss don't do it and then they lied
to us and claimed they did when they did
I was watching video well I mentioned
that uh they Sherlock rolled and when
you see returning troops get treated
like garbage like it just shatters their
confidence and makes them unable to
function in society like it's for our
troops to come back from Iraq and
Afghanistan and be treated like they did
something wrong is the worst morale
destruction of our society I agree yes I
agree but exactly what he's saying you
look back to Vietnam the same thing and
I don't know that I don't think you
could say that men were destroyed from
being men after Vietnam yeah they were
that generation was annihilated they had
no confidence they would they were
completely used and abused
I understand that they were mistreated
someone when they got back but my I
guess my point is you're saying that
where did the men go and I guess so did
they did we lose men being men after
Vietnam or did it happen it happened
after Iraq our current Society this this
flawed narrative that we're we're
struggling with right now as a result of
a lack of male leadership
I agree with that you guys want to hear
a funny factoid do you know why Smith is
the most common last name
Smith Schmidt and other forms of it
because whenever a war would break out
there was one group of people that would
never be sent to war and one group of
people that would never be executed when
a nation was conquered the people that
can make things the blacksmiths yes so
when a war broke out the blacksmiths The
Smiths would stay behind and make
weapons if an enemy Force took over that
country or land they would kill everyone
but the Smiths because they could use
some Smiths kept having kids yep exactly
that's right because they were they were
valuable you needed someone to make the
weapons so my point there is the people
who didn't see the war typically were
the ones that propagated and you know I
think to your point Ian it's actually
more than you realize like Vietnam World
War II we had people come back from
World War II the greatest Generation
Vietnam was destructive I mean people
lost their minds and then you get Iraq
and Afghanistan and also it's just it's
it's Insanity at that point I mean World
War II I think for a lot of people
regardless of your politics there was
something really bad going on in this
world and and my understanding is the US
didn't know the Holocaust was happening
until after they got there later that's
true but that's contended uh there's
polish
contended contested they knew contended
let's figure this out
contending the contestants
listen I'll make all the words up I want
um and it's history so you think they
knew exactly my truth they absolutely
didn't know and they were given
intelligence especially from uh polish
government officials and there was a lot
of photos there was a lot of videos and
they had the opportunity to bomb the
railroads according to the history that
I particularly saw and decided not to
and there was uh you know a lot of
corruption within our government and a
lot of Nazis within our government like
Prescott Bush that of course openly
supported Hitler along with you know the
Rockefellers and other very powerful
families they definitely knew about it
World War II was sort of a defensive War
uh because Hitler had taken France at
that point and the argument they will
try to make it look defensive that's the
whole thing we were attacked by Osama
Bin Laden we must create a war no that
wasn't a defensive war that was a war of
aggression and they used some cheap
pretext for it watch out for the next
one definition of Cambridge English
dictionary Tim contended is a real word
so when you I know it's a real word but
it doesn't make sense in the context in
which you applied it it's like rockets
on the bridge read the definition when
you put rockets on the border of Russia
and then Russia invades to take care of
those Rockets you can't call it a
defensive War because Russia is the one
that crossed the line you put the
Rockets right there on the other side
it's not a war of Defense right now it's
like it's just as aggro as Vietnam it's
nuts yeah would America allow those
weapons on the Mexican board hell no
hell no and like Russia needs black CS
access their Nova sabirsk if Canada had
our entire West Coast had just a strip
of land all down the West Coast
California we didn't have any Pacific
Coast access we would have invaded
nowhere to take that pacific access
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there